it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get the world after
the hobbit and before the lord of the
rings that's so freaking good looking
you might just understand what current
gen is capable of middle earth shadow of
mordor is coming out on pc xbox one and
ps4 with last gen coming out when it's
ready do you remember when the lord of
the rings the two towers movie came out
and everyone was like oh my god these
graphics you guys are like so real
graphics oh my god
well prepare to say that about this open
world of mordor it's been brought to
life in an action role-playing game
level up talion as a ranger and a wraith
through two distinct skill trees and
prepare to take out your enemies the way
you want to and in case you were
wondering gollum will be making an
appearance the adventure begins
september 30th
also this week fans of any turn-based
tactical games get a real treat with
massive chalice coming out on pc mac and
linux but if you thought xcom made you
sad when you named all the characters
after your friends and then they died
prepare to be super depressed as massive
chalice spans generations ensuring that
everyone you know and love will die
check out this super depressing and yet
super fun game on the 28th
and now for a fantasy simulation type
rpg based along the concept of natural
selection
natural doctrine makes its way from
japan to north america and europe this
week on all things playstation play in a
universe where humans fight other races
with magic and swords and it's up to you
jeff the guard soldier to clear out
goblin dens and gather natural resources
important to humankind natural doctrine
debuts on the 30th for north america and
october 3rd for europe
but don't forget this week you get to
relive your glory days as samus or link
or mario fox or kirby or mega man or any
of the infamous characters you stomped
your friends with if only all arguments
could be settled with a match of smash
politics would be so much simpler and
people would be kinder and colors would
be brighter and food would probably
taste better the world is a better place
with smash in it and i'm so glad it's
back and last but not least you go
off-roading with your buddies racing in
some of the most beautiful locations in
the world with forza horizon 2 for xbox
one and 360.
horizon 2 invites you to make your own
path and find the quickest way to the
finish line hey look
start changing gears september 30th
for further details visit gamespot.com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week
you